There's a great line
by Lev Manovich that
says that cinema
essentially became
a new branch of painting,
painting in time.
Think about it.
No other technology
that preceded it
for capturing the numinis
for clothing the numinis,
unfolded in the dimension,
the fourth dimension of time.
So photography, we were able
to take a picture of a moment.
Ecstatic painting, again,
creating a portrait,
a snapshot of an
ephemeral experience.
Whereas, cinema became
this branch of painting
that unfolds in time.
And so, consider that notion.
All of a sudden, we had a
technologically mediated dream
space, a way to access a
portal to the numinis that
unfolded in the
fourth dimension.
So cinema became a
kind of waking dream
where we could travel
in space and time,
where we could travel in mind.
This became more
than virtual reality.
This became a real virtuality,
the simulated catharsis,
the symbolic, allegorical
hero's journey
we got to take every
time we watched a movie.
It became real, right?
It was literalized
in our psyche.
We became literally soul
surfers when we watch movies.
And like the film,
"Inception" says,
the director is able to
architect what is essentially
a dreamspace that
the audience can then
fill with their subconscious.
Linkletter goes even farther.
He says that human beings
knew how to watch movies
because we've been doing it for
hundreds of thousands of years
already in the dreamspace.
And so the reason that it
was so natural, so intuitive,
so innate for us to know
exactly how to watch movies
when these came online,
was because we've
been doing it every
night forever.
So what we see with cinema is
that technological advancements
met consciousness
in a new art form,
giving us access to
new numinis realms.
And I love this
notion because I love
the transformative
capacity of cinema
as a maximum,
ultimate expression
of inner, subjective
explorations,
transpersonal spaces, the spaces
of dreams, the spaces of mine,
the liminal zones.
It's pushing the limits
of theatrical illusion
to see what we can
learn about ourselves.